you mentioned that you used to do
research at night and go to bed at like
6 a.m or 7 A.M
I still do that often
um what uh sleep schedules have you
tried to make for a productive and happy
life like is there
um is there some interesting wild
sleeping patterns that you engaged that
you found that works really well for you
I tried at some point decreasing number
of hours of sleep like a gradually like
a half an hour every few days to this
you know I was hoping to just save time
and that clearly didn't work for me like
at some point there's like a phase shift
and
I felt tired all the time
you know there was a time that I used to
work during the nights the nice thing
about the nights is that no one disturbs
you and even I remember when I was
meeting for the first time with Greg
Brockman his CTO and chairman of openai
our meeting was scheduled to 5 PM
and I overstepped for the meeting
overslept for the meeting at 5 p.m yeah
now you sound like me that's hilarious
okay yeah and at the moment in some
sense
my sleeping schedule also has to do with
the fact that I'm interacting with
people
I sleep without an alarm so so yeah the
the team thing you mentioned extrovert
thing because most humans operate during
a certain set of hours you're forced to
then operate at the same set of hours
but
I'm not quite there yet I found a lot of
Joy just like you said working through
the night
because it's quiet because the world
doesn't disturb you and there's some
aspect
counter to everything you're saying
there's some joyful aspect to sleeping
through the mess of the day
because uh people are having meetings
and sending emails and there's drama
meetings I can sleep through all the
meetings you know I have meetings every
day and they prevent me from having
sufficient amount of time for Focus work
and
then I modified my calendar and I said
that I'm out of office Wednesday
Thursday and Friday every day and I'm
having meetings only Monday and Tuesday
and that was the positively influenced
my mood that I have literally like had
three days for fully focused work yeah
so that there's better solutions to this
problem than staying awake all night